er schrieb karl lauterbach will die
maßnahmen erst lockern wenn 85 prozent
der bevölkerung geimpft sind sie halten
das für falsch warum und dass sie sehr
vorschlag den schönen guten morgen auch
für morgen herr lauterbach
ich denke ist es
natürlich wichtig und da sind wir uns
wahrscheinlich einer meinung dass so
viele menschen wie möglich sich impfen
lassen
selber eben einen impfschutz aufbauen
also sich selber vor dem virus schützen
auch vor der herbst und winter welle wir
müssen aber differenzieren wie wir jetzt
im moment auf die impfzahlen schauen wir
schauen uns ja derzeit wirklich auf die
gesamtbevölkerung an wie viele games
sind das ist jetzt bei 67 prozent
aber es geht ja vor allem darum dass wir
bei der über 60-jährigen die impf
lücke schließen also bei denen die
wirklich ein hohes risiko haben sich zu
infizieren da sind wir bereits bei jeder
einfache impfung bei 86% und wir müssen
natürlich auch den genesenen status mit
rein rechnen also die viele menschen
schon mal eine infektion gehabt haben
und insgesamt jetzt zu sagen wir
brauchen eine bestimmte quote von 85
dass das ist ja nicht realistisch weil
wir das ja dann auch auf die kinder
beziehen dann bräuchten wir unter den
erwachsenen ja passt eine impfquote von
100 prozent das werden wir leider ohne
eine impfpflicht nicht erreichen
erlaubt war
ja sozusagen der also kurse von 85
prozent oder 80 bis 85 prozent sind
natürlich die genesenen mit dabei sie
muss sich mit zählen die zähle ich wie
geimpft das ist gar keine frage und zum
zweiten ist das auch nicht die quote ab
der man also
bestimmte dinge wieder öffnen kann das
machen wir vorher sondern wo wir wieder
ganz normal leben können wo wir alles
öffnen und das ist tatsächlich so aus
dem modell rechnungen an also wehrt er
sich ergibt dann liegen wir darunter
haben wir immer wieder wellen von
erkannten insbesondere in der mittleren
altersgruppe
und diese erkrankten wurden zum teil
auch stark erkranken würden auch planen
die schäden behalten das ist ja die
gruppe die derzeit am stärksten also
auch die intensivbetten füllt und auch
die krankenhausbetten füllt natürlich
kann man also etwas darunter schon alles
wieder öffnen aber dann also dann hat
man mit dem einem rückfall zu rechnen
wir müssen auch damit rechnen wenn wir
zu früh jetzt öffnet sagen wo wir und
sagen 70 prozent bei 70 prozent also
öffnen wir oder 73 würden dann öffnen in
dem sinne dass wieder alles erlaubt ist
dann wussten wir was passiert die
ungeimpften wurden sich sehr schnell
infizieren das wird dann durchlaufen und
bei den bereits geimpften bekommen wir
viele durchbruch infektionen die dann
auch sich infizieren wurden und auch von
denen der krankenlager einige schwer
somit also die komplette öffnung
rückkehr zur normalität was der bürger
sich würden leben wir wieder wie früher
geht es wieder wie früher das setzt
leider eine sehr hohe kombination aus
genesen und geimpft und voraus in der
größenordnung 80 bis 85 prozent
er trägt das würde natürlich den druck
auf die kinder erhöhen soll man
überhaupt diesen druck ausüben sollen
kinder überhaupt werden ja also damals
bei kindern muss man ja differenzieren
bei kindern unter 12 jahren gibt es
einfach keinen impfstoff und da müssen
wir auch gar nicht drüber diskutieren
also ob in der altersgruppe geimpft
werden sollte oder nicht
in der gruppe von zwölf bis 18 jahren da
hat die stiko jahren empfehlung
ausgesprochen dass man die gruppe impfen
also eine impfung empfehlen würde aber
man muss natürlich aufpassen dass man da
jetzt nicht einen druck ausübt auch auf
kinder dass die sich impfen lassen
müssen das ist wirklich eine freie
entscheidung auch für die kinder und die
eltern natürlich man kann es sollte es
an raten weil die impfung dem risiko
einer infektion überwiegt aber man muss
jetzt man muss aufpassen dass man keinen
druck auf die kinder aus lauterbach
sollten kinder und jugendliche für sie
geimpft sein
keinen druck ausüben der stimmigkeit
strikt zu das geht gar nicht aber man
sollte den kindern die impfung anbieten
die zwölf- bis 17-jährigen kinder nehmen
die impfung die auch gerne andere wir
jetzt sehen lassen sich empfinden da ist
gar kein druck notwendig das wird also
im späten herbst und im winter noch
zunehmen die impfung für diejenigen die
zwischen fünf und zwölf sind wird
demnächst kommen ich hoffe dass da eine
schnelle zulassung der europäischen
zulassungsbehörde kommt da verhilft man
weniger impfstoff ungefähr ein drittel
der dosis die studien bis dahin sind
auch alle sehr vielversprechend aber wie
gesagt kein druck und viele kinder
wünschen sich die impfung werden gerne
geimpft und sie wünschen sich am leben
wieder teilnehmen zu können komplett
keine schulausfall daher die kinder
sollten die impfungen angeboten bekommen
aber keiner sollte sich impfen müssen
lauterbach die regierung erhöht auch den
druck auf ungeimpfte unter anderem mit
der zweig regel halten sie das für
richtig diesen druck auszuüben auf
ungeimpfte
ja das muss man ehrlicherweise also zu
geben ich bespreche über das nicht also
vom druck auf ungeimpfte also die 2g
regel so darzustellen als wenn man damit
also quasi die ungeimpften zur impfung
drängen schieben wollte oder durch die
hintertür zwingen wollte dass man das
macht um eine strafe der ungeimpften zu
erreichen das ist nicht der fall darum
geht es hier gar nicht sondern die 2g
nun ist eine möglichkeit die ungeimpften
vor ihrem eigenen infektions also
problem zu schützen weil wenn ich jetzt
tatsächlich als ungeimpfter unterwegs
bin in einem klub zum beispiel und das
vorher getestet wurden worden es ist
aber ein infektiöser übersehen worden
dann sind es leider die ungeimpften die
sehr stark erkrankte die sehr schwer
erkranken wie infizierten geimpften
erkranken nicht so stark aber die
ungeimpften der kranken stark daher ist
das in erster linie eine maßnahme mit
der wir insgesamt das
infektionsgeschehen herunterfahren und
womit wir auch die ungeimpften schützen
das darzustellen als wenn man das nur
machen würde um druck auf die
ungeimpften ausüben das ist keine
epidemiologie oder keine public health
politik sondern es einfach nur politik
dann steht man es so dass ging es nicht
um die gesundheit dieser menschen
sondern um eine maßnahme mit der wir
quasi den impfzwang durch die hintertür
einführen wollten das wollen wir nicht
ist seine rein medizinische maßnahme sie
ist sinnvoll herr lauterbach wissen sie
was ich nicht verstehe warum spielen
eigentlich antikörper hier gar keine
rolle mehr ich frage dass auch aus
persönlichem interesse denn ich hatte
selbst corona im letzten jahr im
dezember ein halbes jahr danach
geld ich nicht mehr als genesen quasi
ich habe mich aber testen lassen ich
habe sehr sehr gute antikörper das
spielt aber keine rolle warum nicht
ja das ist tatsächlich eine stiko also
entscheidung man könnte tatsächlich die
antikörper sehr viel
interessanter nutzen das will das
derzeit touren weil wir wissen dass der
genesenen status sehr gut schütz am
anfang sei es zeit was es so aus als
wenn die impfung besser schützen würde
als der genesenen status das hat sich
als falsch erwiesen das ist einfach
nicht richtig also wir wissen heute dass
der gelesenen status sehr umfänglich
schützt und wir wissen auch dass der
genesenen status ganz gut schützt über
die sechs also monate hinaus von daher
könnte ich mir vorstellen dass wir den
genesenen status also mit dem antikörper
also nach was so nutzen dass man auch
über die sechs monate hinaus noch als
genesen gilt das war keine politische
entscheidung sondern das ist eine
steko entscheidungen es gibt für und
wider ich dich kennt sich da auch sehr
gut aus ich glaube wir haben darüber
auch schon mehrfach gesprochen und haben
wir doch gewähren
da sehe ich nicht passiert herr stricker
warum es nicht passiert ist das kann ich
auch nicht beantworten habe ich stimme
vollkommen überein der schutz nach einer
infektion ist genauso gut gegen korona
vorhanden wenn man antikörper hat wie
wenn man geimpft ist vielleicht sogar
besser langfristig das wissen wir noch
nicht aber ich denke auch dass man
antikörpertest eigentlich zu lassen
sollte eis genesenen status damit wir
den leuten eben auch eine reine die
möglichkeit geben einen nachweis zu
haben wenn der alte pcr-test verfällt
oder einfach von dem zeitpunkt gar kein
pc hat es vorliegt rät karl lauterbach
hat gerade gesagt er befürwortet wird
ganz klar die 2g regel das sei kein
druck durch die hintertür
tatsächlich entsteht aber doch dadurch
eine zweiklassengesellschaft eine
aufkündigung der solidargemeinschaft ja
also das interessante hierbei ist dass
wissenschaftlich stimme ich herrn
lauterbach vollkommen überein es stimmt
dass in einem wenn in einem club eine
zweig regel gibt und die geimpften
vielleicht ein infizierter übersehen
wurde und auch unter geimpften
infektionen stattfinden die sind
geschützt werden keinen schweren verlauf
haben also es ist ein eigenschutz und
länder aber ungeimpfte dabei sind die
haben eher das risiko einen schweren
verlauf zu haben also von dem aspekt
stimme ich vollkommen überein aber ihr
das am ende ist eine politische frage
dahinter ob man dem bürger die
verantwortung über seinen über seinen
eigenen körper über seine eigenes leben
nicht selber zurückgeben sollte und auch
eine selbstverantwortung haben sollte ob
sie hat sich dem risiko aussetzen oder
nicht irgendwann werden wir zu diesem
punkt kommen ein test ist im grunde ein
sehr guter weg um auch sich
freizeit also um zu zeigen dass man
keine infektion hat und ich denke man
muss eine alternative anbieten den
ungeimpften dass sie sich auch dass sie
am sozialen leben teilnehmen können
was nämlich ansonsten passiert ist dass
geimpfte und ungeimpfte sich auf trennen
nicht mehr
vermengen und wir damit einmal den
herden effekt der durch die impfung
immer noch da ist also nicht herren
immunität aber eine verringerung der
infektionsketten verlieren und auf der
anderen seite ungeimpfte ja nicht
aufhören am sozialen leben teilzunehmen
die werden sich dann gemeinsam treffen
neben einem fußballspiel die kämpfen
sind im stadium die ungeimpften treffen
sich zu hause im privaten und dann
kriegen wir eher mal auch ausbrüche die
wir nicht kontrollieren können herr
lauterbach ihre entgegnung also
zunächst einmal also die
ungeimpften wenn die 2g regel also geht
die können ja weiter am sozialen leben
teilnehmen es sind nur bestimmte
bereiche wo sie dann nicht teilnehmen
können zum beispiel in clubs wo laut
gesprochen oder gesungen wird war musik
läuft weil es da sehr gefährlich ist es
gibt andere bereiche da geht für die
ungeimpften nach wie vor das soziale
leben so weiter wie es immer war und das
ist auch keine diskriminierung ich will
versuchen das einander beispiel
festzumachen also wenn ich
beispielsweise ein schwimmbad habe und
es gibt einen teil im schwimmbad da ist
das wasser sehr tief kein boden dann
dürfen dort die nicht schwimmer nicht
rein dann könnte man auch sagen aber das
ist doch die freiheit der
nichtschwimmer- die dürfen auch in den
tiefen teil aber ich will ja nicht dass
sie ertrinken und daher machen wir
diesen teil dann frei nur für schwimmer
und der also unser tal wo es wasser
nicht so tief ist da dürfen auch die
nicht schwimmer ryan aber ich kann nicht
zulassen mit dem argument naja die
dürfen doch auch schwimmen teilnehmen
sodass die dass die nicht schwimmer dann
dort ertrinken das möchte ich nicht und
das mag zunächst mal als ein weit
hergeholt das bild betrachtet werden
aber es gibt tatsächlich situationen man
es wegen kleiner klub viele leute darin
auch ein paar leute darin die vielleicht
nicht mehr die jüngsten sind es wird
getrunken laut gesprochen die aero so
konzentration ist sehr hoch dann ist das
so gefährlich wieder nicht schwimmer der
vielleicht ein bisschen schwimmen kann
aber nicht wirklich gut ich muss diese
menschen voreinander schützen und sie
auch selbst schützen und im übrigen wenn
er nicht schwimmer ertrinkt das ist
grauenvoll das will niemand aber es ist
nur dann nicht immer selbst er wollte
schwimmen wenn aber derjenige jetzt sich
infiziert in club der infiziert sich ja
nicht nur selbst und wird schwer krank
sondern er steckt auch viele andere an
und am anfang war es auch noch gar nicht
dass er infiziert ist somit glaube ich
schon gibt es gute gründe aber nur
natürlich in den besonders gefährlichen
situationen also nicht in jeder sozialen
interaktion denn nicht geimpfte darf
natürlich an breiten sozialen leben
teilnehmen das ist klar trotzdem sie
sagen dass es keine diffamierung allein
wenn man ihnen jetzt zugehört hat allein
die wortwahl die ungeimpften ist auf
jeden fall eine stigmatisierung wenn man
sich vorstellt eltern wollen ihre kinder
auf einen kindergeburtstag schicken nun
mal fragt dann sind die auch geimpft
oder sind die nicht geimpft es wird auf
jeden fall zu einer stigmatisierung
aber wieso also wenn ich also danach
frage wenn jetzt meine eigenen kinder
zum beispiel da sind und ich frage ob
die anderen kinder geimpft sind das
recht habe ich doch wenn ich meine
eigenen kinder schützen will es kann
jedoch nicht als stigmatisierung
ausgelegt werden wenn ich danach frage
wenn wir jetzt hier zusammen feiern sind
meine eigenen kinder gefährdet sei tier
geimpft eine formulierung im norden von
der formulierung die ungeimpften allein
allein darum geht es mir schon ich bin
ja ich habe meine darunter gähnt wieder
momente natürlich aber nach mit herrn
schicke ich möchte ja nicht ich oder ins
spiel holen herr lauterbach und über die
inzidenz zahlen sprechen da steht die
frage im raum ob mit horrorzahlen
panikmache gemacht worden ist
beispielsweise kanzleramtschef helge
braun hat für den september eine zahl
von 850
prognostiziert aktuell sind wir bei
knapp über 60 war das panikmache den
strich wenn ich einen satz noch zum
schwimmbecken sagen darf das problem ist
ja nicht nur die öffentlichen räume aber
die menschen wollen eben schwimmen und
die menschen wollen eben auch feiern und
tanzen und auch genauso die nicht
geimpft sind wollen feiern und tanzen da
muss man ihr bei mir jetzt bei der
schwimmbecken analog analogie bleibt
dann ist es eben so dass sie sich zu
hause ihren pool mit tiefen bereich
aufbauen und dann dort schwimmen und
dort dann wahrscheinlich vielleicht auch
trinken könnten also ich glaube dadurch
dass wir aber in einem öffentlichen
bereich ja auch eine gewisse aufsicht
haben dass wir eine kontakt nach
verfolgungs möglichkeit haben und auch
mit tests kontrollieren können ob jemand
infiziert ist oder nicht haben das haben
wir im privaten bereich eben nicht und
die leute werden zu hause zusammenkommen
und feiern und gerade jetzt im herbst
und winter ihre weihnachtsfeiern haben
das für mich die frage ist es besser
nicht so was im offenen im öffentlichen
bereich zu haben wo wir dann auch einen
gewissen möglichkeit haben die
infektionsketten zu unterbinden zu
kontrollieren oder soll das wieder ganz
im privaten stattfinden ich glaube von
public health aspekt ist es besser dass
das wir da keine trennung machen
zwischen geimpften und ungeimpften zu
den zahlen also zu den incidents zahlen
noch mal war es ja ein interessanter
punkt ich will nicht wieder sprechen
einfach unwidersprochen zu haben wir
sind hier nicht in einem politischen
austausch ich finde die argumente strege
interessant aber ich glaube es ist
trotzdem nicht richtig ist und zwar
deshalb wenn jetzt also in diesem großen
räumen viele leute zusammenkommen und
alba ist infiziert dann haben wir sofort
als obersten ereignis wie beispielsweise
jetzt bei dieser zweig veranstaltung in
münster wovon 350 jungen leute genießen
83 also sich infiziert haben wenn das
viele ungeimpfte gewesen wären dann
hätten wir sehr schwere verläufe gesehen
der die verläufe sind bei den geimpften
viel plan doch viel leichter somit ich
glaube dass sie recht haben dass ich
dann ein stück des geschehens in das
private verlagert aber ich habe nicht
private feiern also wo ich 350 leute
unterbringen und von daher parzelliert
das ganze sich aber es ist trotzdem also
einen rebound aus zum teil haben sie
recht ich glaube dass kompensiert aber
den schutz den schutz mechanismus nicht
ganz kommen nochmal zu den zahlen her
strecke war das panikmache mit
horrorzahlen ja also ich glaube den der
fehler der gemacht wurde ist dass wir
uns zu sehr auf die prognosen verlassen
haben oder ein stück weit erst mal
geglaubt haben dass es jetzt bare münze
das ist das was der nostradamus
vorhergesehen hat so wird sie werden
sich die zahlen entwickeln
wir haben dabei in der kommunikation
vergessen und auch in der politik wurde
vor allem diese kommunikation vergessen
dass wir dass es sich um eine prognose
handelt dass es eine modellrechnung es
dass diese aber auch sehr falsch liegen
können für mich ist ein schönes beispiel
eigentlich der typischen modellrechnung
ist der wetterbericht es ist eben leider
so dass der wetterbericht zu 70 prozent
richtig liegt aber er liegt eben auch
mal falsch wir alle kennen die situation
wo wir rausgehen und es ist es sonne
angesagt und es fängt dann doch an zu
regnen und so muss man ein bisschen auch
die modelle verstehen und nicht sagen
wir werden dorthin kommen sondern auch
immer mit kommunizieren das gehört eben
zur transparenz und der wahrheit der
wissenschaft dazu dass wir diese
ja diese diese unwägbarkeit dabei mit
kommunizieren kurze antwort von ihnen
darauf noch zum schluss herr lauterbach
dass sich auch so allerdings die meisten
prognosen die ganz grob daneben lagen
das waren keine modellrechnungen sondern
das war einschätzungen zum beispiel
helge braun hatte hier also überschlagen
also wie das infektionsgeschehen sich
entwickeln könnte und man muss auch dazu
sagen es gibt modellrechnungen sind
besser und es gibt modellrechnungen die
sind schlechter wir haben ein breites
spektrum in deutschland und es gehört
mit zu den lehren aus der pandemie das
wäre ein zentrum aufbauen müssen für
qualitativ hochwertige modellrechnungen
denn da hatten wir tatsächlich
qualitätsdefizite
[Musik]